Well that's it for the four plus one views, but
I think there are some other views which are sometimes useful in understanding,
or conveying your understanding,
of a system that you're trying to build at the architectural level.
One that I've found quite useful is a feature view.
A feature is a conceptual unit of system behavior from the user's point of view.
Your camera has a zooming feature available to it.
Or maybe it doesn't, okay?
Typically, features are something which manufacturers provide as options,
that you may have to pay extra for.
Feature modeling is used for describing a set of features that
a a collection of related applications provide.
There's feature diagram, which I'm going to show you in a second,
that conveys the set of possible features that might be
configured into a particular product in that set of products.
The diagram is graphical.
It has icons and so on, but it can also have intra-feature constrains which
aren't shown in this particular diagram.
Here's a particular feature diagram showing the features of a car.
At the top is the, what's called the concept or the main
manufactured item and then under it are its features.
So the car, this particular car has four features.
Okay.
Three of the features are required.
The body, the transmission, and engine.
And whether or not it pulls trailer is optional.
Whether it's required or optional is indicated by the little circle at
the end of arc connecting cart to its features.
If the circle is filled in it's a required feature, and
if it's open; then it's an optional feature.
Features can have sub-features.
So, a transition sorry, a transmission can have
an automatic transmission feature, or a manual transmission feature.
The or that I just said, is indicated by that open arc connecting those
two lines coming out of the transition.
Similarly there are two kinds of engines, electrical and gasoline.
In this case the arc is filled in though,
indicating that you can have a combination.
That is you can have a hybrid engine.
We could imagine a constraint here going between automatic transmission and
pulls trailer, saying that the pulls trailer option is only available if
you have the automatic transmission and not the manual transmission.